first I want to give Megan Kelly credit
on the internet we did this on your show
the other day but I want it to be on the
Ruben report as well because about two
years ago it's almost two years ago that
I was on your show and it was before
DeSantis had even run for re-election or
was running for president we were
getting into the Trump Dan santis thing
and you said that the Trump people are
ride or die they're never going to break
it's going to be impossible for Dan
santis and I I watched the clip again we
played it on your show a couple days ago
and I watched it again this morning and
I was thinking what was going on in my
head at that time and I think what I
really thought having just moved to
Florida was that Co was going to play a
much larger role in this election that
people it was so fresh at the time that
I thought this is going to be the thing
that is going to drive people to vote or
make decisions and clearly that just
didn't turn out to be
so after the Iowa caucus I give Megan
Kelly some credit you called it right
sister you deserve the credit thanks
Dave I understand exactly what you are
saying about where you were and and it
has been kind of remarkable how even
Republicans have moved past covid and
don't want to talk about it it's like
why wouldn't you want to talk about it
what if we get another leader in there
who does this to us again I mean you
think about Trump with all du respect to
Trump he's one of those leaders who did
that to us yeah he now says he didn't
lock us down but he did lock us down and
not only did he lock us down for those
two weeks but he was calling up
Governors like DeSantis urging them to
keep the lockdowns going and chastising
them when they didn't all that's been
swept under the rug and not to mention
the stuff with fouchi even gopers don't
want to talk about it I I do want to
talk about it I can see why you thought
the Republicans who were at least on the
better side of that would want to talk
about it but I just feel like maybe it
was too much trauma and people just
wanted to forget about it and that did
not help Ronda santis what does that
tell you about the American people or
what even the results we can throw the
results up real quick of Iowa everyone
knows already Trump got a little over uh
50% about 51% he got 20 delegates Dan
santis came in second 21% eight
delegates Nikki just right behind him
19% seven delegates I mean what does
that sort of thing like we went through
three years of covid craziness something
that none of us could have ever imagined
a mere four years ago we go through all
that and then it has no bearing on this
initial caucus at least I don't know
it's I expected more from the Republican
party I knew why the Democrats would
want to move on they did it to us they
advocated the wrong things they
suppressed our speech on their
controversial moves so I can 100% see
why they'd move on but why did the
Republicans allow it to go and I all I
can return to is they're it was
traumatic they don't want to discuss it
they know they were right they know they
were right about the lab leak theory
about the masks not working about the V
vaccines being not really vaccines and
having potential health risks and
instead of wanting to sort of bask in
the glory of having been so right on so
many things they're just angry and they
want to move on only this core
constituency of like RFK J supporters
wants to continue talking about it and
the rest of the GOP is like let's not go
there it's done you know we'll never let
it happen again but let's move on
because they just don't want to relive
it is that partly because Trump has such
a strangle hold on the party for Better
or For Worse and in that he did give
fouchy an award on the way out I think
three weeks before leaving office he was
asking
there's a document proving this he was
asking Dan santis to shut down again as
you had alluded to warp speed etc etc
like if they were to really focus on it
again and if we were really to get a
reckoning a lot of that would kind of be
aimed at him I don't think that's why I
think that maybe there's some core Trump
supporters who don't want to talk about
it in the same way they don't want to
talk about anything that Trump has done
that you know is controversial but I
don't I get the same sense for from
so-called regular Republicans the
normies you know the ones who aren't
hardcore aaga who are just sort of like
you know walking along doing their
Republican thing but not thinking about
politics all the way or Trump I think
they've they all want to move on that's
my impression even on the show you can
kind of see if you do a segment on covid
are people responding well to it does it
get a lot of numbers when you cut it as
an individual clip no not at all and I
don't have a hardcore magga audience I
have some magga supporters and some not
I just think that they don't want to
talk about it it's it's too upsetting
they're they were ready to move on from
it after the two weeks never mind after
you know years it was a bad chapter they
got sucked into involuntary measures
that they didn't want to do with respect
to themselves and their children and I
think they'd fight like hell if this
came back around but I think right now
they get it they figured out who the Bad
actors are and they just don't have any
desire to dwell
there